the only thing scarier than this picture
is this picture it's episode 8 of IMG
I just recently found these shirts and I
love them they come in pairs and they're
battery-powered
when you're far away from the person
wearing the matching shirt your hearts
are only partially lit but when you come
together you have full health last week
awkward family photos got a TV deal from
ABC I don't really know what the show's
gonna be like but these are some of my
favorites of course the ultimate isn't
the awkward family it's the awesome
grandma pictures of this guy are surging
on BuzzFeed today is he a male model the
next cast member of the Jersey Shore a
pimp a habitual nipple pincher no he is
Justin Bieber's dad remember when Bush
dodged that shoe well this morning Obama
was almost hit by a thrown book The
Daily Mail caught this photo of the book
in flight and right now no one's sure
what the book was or even who threw it
but I kid you not this naked man was
arrested at the very same event and
anime makeup
and look everything's normal before you
see the shadows and bricks is one of my
favorite places to browse and this one's
pretty cool can you tell me what's
strange about these three guys and where
they are
answer it's actually a picture of four
guys wait what's wrong with this girl's
legs bro Bible expose the tricks girls
used to make themselves look hotter on
Facebook the never smile the hugs the
kiss and the ugly girl comparison
composition but if you want to see a
really hideous Facebook profile check
out the first link in this video's
description I can't even put it on
YouTube but trust me I can't even tell
if it's a boy or a girl
click the link check it out and let me
know what you think animals eating other
animals and an animal eating a kid but
on facebook.com slash Vsauce gaming
we've got even more so make your own
favorite images of the week there like
polly did kim you suck hugh reminded us
that sports are not alone and just how
sad it would be if computer mice were
real months that's it for now click any
of these squares to watch previous
episodes and thanks for watching
[Music]